bisher wurde im ganzen universum nur ein
solches signal entdeckt ein fr be der
sich wiederholte also an fast ray burst
ein extrem kurzes aber auch extrem
starkes signal
jetzt wurde mit einem neuartigen
teleskop ein zweites sich wiederholende
signal mit dieser stärke aufgefangen was
das phänomen aber nicht minder retzlaff
macht wer sendet diese signale und warum
oder sind es doch natürliche phänomene
klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt's täglich faszinierendes
seines videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen das neue signal
wurde mit dem neuen teleskop in kanada
erfasst der erste fab wurde 2012
entdeckt und 2015 wurde mit dem arecibo
radioteleskope rico festgestellt dass er
sich wiederholt dieses signal der fast
ray burst 12 11 0 2 kurz efa b12 nur
zwei ist wirklich sehr seltsam
er stammt aus einer metallarmen
zwerggalaxien und etwa drei milliarden
jahre ist er von uns entfernt das heißt
diese signale wurden ausgesandt als hier
auf der erde gerade mal ein paar
einzeller herumschwimmen es dauerte noch
eine weitere milliarde jahre bis die
ersten mehrzeller entstanden von
menschlichem leben mal ganz abgelehnt
aber wie kann das dann sein dass aus
dieser galaxie ständig diese extrem
kurzen radio signale ausgesandt werden
es gibt zahlreiche astro physische
theorien aber sie alle können nicht
erklären wie sich ein solches signal
ständig wiederholen kann andere
fahrzeuge börse sind dann auch einmal
aufgetreten und dann nie wieder
was ist hier anders für die breakthrough
listen initiative ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit deshalb hoch das ist
ein signal einer intelligenten spezies
sein könnte eine art warnsignal ein
funkfeuer das waren oder eine art
ortsschild ist es könnte aber auch eine
zivilisation sein die die energie eines
ganzen sterns nutzen kann um riesige
raumtransporter mit solchen radio
blitzen anzutreiben für zivilisationen
gibt es die katastophe skala sie besagt
welche energie eine zivilisation nutzen
kann
die menschheit ist hier knapp unter dem
wert 1 wir können knapp die gesamte
energie unseres planeten nutzen ab dem
wert 2 kann eine zivilisation die
energie seines zentralgestirns nutzen
und ab dem wert 3 die der gesamten
heimat ballack
die eine katastophe zwei zivilisation
könnte mit hilfe ihres zentralsterns
solche radio blitze aus senden und als
antrieb für raumschiffe nutzen etwa big
12 11 02 wurde ja 2012 entdeckt und dann
erst später wurde diese wiederkehrenden
eva beuys aus demselben system gefunden
und jetzt wurde wieder ein solch
wirklich sehr seltsames signal gefunden
registriert wurde fab 18 08 14 am 14
august 2010 zum ersten mal und
wiederholte sich dann insgesamt sechs
mal wie jetzt in der zeitschrift nature
veröffentlicht wurde und immer noch gibt
es keine erklärung für diese signale
allerdings ist bei dem neuen signal
einiges anders die quelle ist nur halb
so weit entfernt wie die von fab 12 11
02 und das signal ist niederfrequente
cherry von der university of toronto
die entdeckung der signale in
niedrigeren frequenzbereichen bedeutet
nun dass wir einige theorien überdenken
müssen
was auch immer die quellen dieser
radiosignale sind es ist sehr
faszinierend zu sehen über welch ein
breites frequenzspektrum sie verteilt
sind
es gibt einige erste erklärungsansätze
die jedoch keine niedrig frequenzen es
erlauben und die somit nun offenbar
ausscheiden denn das ist bisher wirklich
das problem der fbs erklärung für
erklärung scheidet aus und jetzt zu
einem video das euch wissen schmackhaft
macht über iran hawking und social media
ist
darian bei wissen schmeckt hier
draufklicken wer sich für kochen und
wissenschaft interessiert sollte den
kanal unbedingt abonnieren kommentiert
das video fleißig und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran